Prof: So we're going
through the development of the
theory and practice of organic
chemistry, generation by
generation.
We started with Lavoisier,
and then Berzelius and
Gay-Lussac and Davy.
And last time we did Dumas and
Liebig and Wöhler.
And now we're onto the next
generation, people that were
born around 1830.
And the new developments are
going to be valence and benzene.
Remember, in this list,
things that are in boldface are
experimental and things that are
theoretical are in normal face.
So valence and -- and benzene
is experimental,
but what we're interested in is
the theory of benzene here.
And the people who are
associated with this are August
Kekulé
--
and you've all heard of
Kekulé
structures and Kekulé
benzene,
and he's memorialized on the
front of the building here.
He was born in 1829.
But few of you probably have
heard of Archibald Couper,
who is not on the front of the
building, and was born two years
later in 1831.
This is Couper as a student.
He lived to a reasonable age,
sixty-one-years-old,
but everything he did,
he did early.
He was sort of a dilettante
student.
He was a native of Scotland and
studied in Edinburgh,
but also went to Berlin often.
And he studied classics and
metaphysics, logic,
moral philosophy;
went to a lot of concerts.
But while in Berlin he got
fascinated by chemistry.
So in 1855 he became a student
chemist.
And in 1856 he went to Paris to
work with Wurtz,
who was the other leading
French chemist,
and worked indeed on salicylic
acid;
as you have done.
In 1858, while in Wurtz's lab,
he got fired,
for reasons that you'll see,
and he went back to Scotland
and tried to make a career
there.
But soon he had a mental
breakdown, and the rest of his
life he didn't do anything.
Okay?
But what he did in 1858 is
really something.
Okay?
So he didn't get a stone on the
front of our building.
But on this building,
which is "To Let",
or at least was a few years
ago, in Kirkintilloch,
which is about eight miles
northeast of Glasgow,
in Scotland, there's a stone.
And it says:
"This plaque marks the
birthplace of Archibald Scott
Couper whose brilliant
pioneering contributions to
chemical theory have won for him
international renown,
and whose genius,
stifled by an early illness,
was denied the opportunity of
consummation."
When he was recovering from his
first breakdown,
he went fishing on this Endrick
Water,
north of Glasgow,
and got sunstroke,
which did him in for the rest
of his life.
And that's where he lived.
His mother nursed him for his
final 33 years in this house in
Kirkintilloch.
So this is the paper.
He tried to publish it in
French.
He submitted it to his boss,
Wurtz,
in the hopes that he would put
it in the French journal,
but Wurtz thought it was not
such a --
it was a little rash as a
paper, and put it in his desk to
cool off for awhile.
And in the meantime
Kekulé
published,
which irritated Couper no
little, and he told Wurtz what
he thought about it,
which was why he got sacked.
But he also published it in
English, and later it was
published in French.
But so this is the English
version, not the first version
he wrote;
by Archibald Scott Couper.
And the first sentence already
is fascinating.
"The end of
chemistry"
(that is, the goal of
chemistry) "is its
theory."
Not many people would have said
that.
They would have had more
practical motivations for
chemistry.
But Couper was a big thinker.
He said: "The guide in
chemical research is a theory.
It is therefore of the greatest
importance to ascertain whether
the theories at present adopted
by chemists are adequate to the
explanation of chemical
phenomena,
or at least,
based upon the true principles
which ought to regulate
scientific research."
So what were the theories that
were prevalent at this time,
by 1850?
Name one.
Prof: Shai?
Student:  Dualism.
Prof: Dualism;
okay, the radical theory.
That was prevalent in Germany.
How about elsewhere,
like France?
Student:  Substitution.
Prof: The substitution,
or type, or unitary theory.
Okay, so those were the big
theories.
"Among those which have
been lately developed,
there is one,
on account of its apparent
numerous merits,
which particularly claims
investigation,
and respecting which we deem
that it would not be
unprofitable were either new
proofs of its scientific value
furnished or,
on the contrary,
should considerations be
adduced establishing not only
its inadequacy to the
explanation,
but its ultimate detriment to
the progress of science.
I allude to the system of types
as advocated by Gerhardt."
So Gerhardt and Laurent,
who were slightly second-level
French chemists,
were the ones who really came
up with the idea of the type
theory.
But Dumas adopted and advocated
it, and was the leader.
So this was the theory that was
going on in the lab where he was
present, in Paris.
So page 106 of this paper,
on the French type theory,
he said:
"Should the principle
which is therein adopted be
applied to common events of
life, it will be found that it
is simply absurd.
Suppose that some one were to
systematize the formation of
letters into words that formed
the contents of a book.
Were he to begin by saying that
he had discovered a certain word
which would serve as a
type" (remember there were
four types;
water, ammonia,
HCl and hydrogen) "and
from which by substitution and
double decomposition all the
others are to be derived,
that he by this means not only
could form new words,
but new books,
and books almost ad infinitum;
he would state certainly an
empirical truth."
That is, you can take some word
and substitute letters,
or pairs of letters,
or sets of letters,
for other letters,
and get any word you want.
Okay?
"At the same time,
however, this method would,
judged by the light of common
sense, be an absurdity.
But a principle which common
sense brands with absurdity is
philosophically false and a
scientific blunder."
So this was not likely to make
him popular in Paris.
So here's what he was doing,
actually, right?
The Emperor's new clothes.
He's a new guy on the block,
right?
He's only been a chemist for
two years, only begun studying
chemistry two years before,
and says what everybody's doing
is nonsense, in France.
Well how about in Germany?
That's where he was before,
in Berlin.
"I can only remark that it
is not merely an unprofitable
figure of language,
but is injurious to science,
inasmuch as it tends to arrest
scientific inquiry by adopting
the notion that these quasi
elements…"
What does he mean by the quasi
elements;
what are they?
Student:  Compound
radicals.
Prof: Compound radicals,
right?
"…contain some
unknown and ultimate power,
which it is impossible to
explain."
That is, okay,
so you got radicals.
What holds the radicals
together?
Right?
"It stifles inquiry at the
very point where an explanation
is demanded,
by putting the seal of
elements, of ultimate powers,
on bodies which are known to be
anything but this."
They're definitely not
elements, because you can burn
them, of course,
and get water and CO_2 and so
on.
Okay?
So this was absolutely true;
on both counts,
both the French and the German
theory.
But it was stated pretty
undiplomatically.
Right?
And especially for someone
who'd only been studying
chemistry for two years.
Maybe it took someone who was
only studying chemistry two
years to see how stupid it was.
Right?
But at any rate,
he got in trouble because of
this.
What did he offer as an
alternative?
To look at the properties of
the elements themselves,
not of radicals,
not of these planetary systems
that were the types.
"Science demands the
strict adherence to a principle
in direct contradiction to this
view.
That first principle,
without which research cannot
advance a step,
dare not be ignored;
namely, that a whole is simply
the derivative of its
parts."
So you have to understand the
elements, and then you can
understand assemblies of
elements from that.
That's not obviously true.
In fact, I think you could make
a pretty good argument that as
you get things more complicated,
they're not simply a sum of
their parts.
But that's what he said.
"As a consequence of this,
it follows that it is
absolutely necessary to
scientific unity and research to
consider these bodies as
entirely derivative,
and as containing no secret
ultimate power whatever,
and that the properties which
these so-called quasi elements
possess are a direct consequence
of the properties of the
individual elements of which
they are made up."
So study the elements,
not the radicals.
And he began by saying he'll
focus on carbon;
which is not surprising for an
organic chemist.
"In applying this method,
I propose at present to
consider the single element,
carbon.
This body is found to have two
highly distinguishing
characteristics.
(1) It combines with equal
numbers of hydrogen,
chlorine, oxygen,
sulfur, etc."
Would you agree with that?
How could he say so?
It's because he wasn't dealing
with the right atomic weights,
right?
Okay?
"It enters into chemical
union with itself."
So those are the two things:
that it'll unite with itself,
not just with other things,
the way dualism would like you
to do;
and it combines with -- it has
a certain combining power.
"These two properties,
in my opinion,
explain all that is
characteristic of organic
chemistry."
So 1858 marks a new frontier in
organic chemistry;
a completely new revelation:
The tetravalence and
self-linking of carbon.
That's points one and two,
right?
That it combines with a certain
number of other things and it
can link to itself.
Right?
Now here he shows the formula
of methane, of CO_2,
and of carbon tetrachloride.
But those are the atomic
weights he's using,
in order to get these formulas.
Notice he says:
"Here the whole four of
hydrogen are not bound by a
mutual affinity."
You know that they're not all
collected together because you
can substitute them one by one;
one chlorine,
two chlorines,
three chlorines.
"For each element of
hydrogen can be substituted for
one of chlorine in regular
series,
beginning with the first and
ending with the last.
The atoms of oxygen are,
on the contrary,
united in pairs."
What does he mean by that,
that the oxygens are united in
pairs?
Why are they united in pairs in
his formulas,
drawn by those curly brackets,
like they had in type theory?
Yes Angela?
Student:  Probably one
oxygen, because the -- they were
probably one oxygen because his
weight is half of it.
Prof: Ah ha,
because he had half the atomic
weight.
So they always came in pairs;
to get oxygen sixteen,
if he thinks oxygen is eight.
"The atoms of oxygen are
in pairs which will be more
fully developed hereafter."
Not in this paper.
But there was no hereafter,
because of his breakdown,
okay?
"And only for two atoms of
oxygen two chlorines can be
substituted; thus."
So you can start with CO_2,
get a phosgene and carbon
tetrachloride.
"In the same manner with
bodies that contain multiples of
C^2 united to hydrogen."
So carbon is the same deal.
It always comes in pairs,
because its atomic weight is
six instead of twelve.
Okay.
"Take the inverse of this.
If the four atoms of hydrogen
were bound together,
we could evidently expect to
form such bodies as H^4^(
)Cl^4."
Right?
If the four were all held
together and could make four
bonds, then you could get H^4^(
)Cl^4, or these other compounds.
"One would naturally
expect to find carbon
substituted for chlorine,
and find bodies like
H^4_, Cl^2,
C^2, and so on.
These bodies are not only
unknown,
but the whole history of
hydrogen might be investigated
and not a single instance be
found in favor of the opinion
that it has any affinity for
itself,
when in union with another
element."
Okay?
Remember, getting all the
chlorines together was
Schwindler's idea.
Okay, so here,
now that he have the idea that
these atoms associate together,
it makes sense to talk about a
structure.
Right?
What's connected to what's
connected to what?
You know, the toe-bone and the
ankle-bone and all that stuff.
Okay, so now you could write
structural formulas.
So these were the very first
structural formulae,
because before this there was
no such thing as structure.
Okay?
Thus methylic alcohol has this
formula, and ethylic alcohol has
the other.
So now do you see the theme
here?
What's he using to denote bonds?
Prof: Three dots are a
bond.
So he has a carbon bonded to
three H's, and also to OOH.
That's because oxygen is
doubled, right?
So we would write it this way.
Or ethyl alcohol we would write
that way.
Or this compound.
Now, this one has a printer's
error in it.
What is it, and what's the
printer's error?
What's the substance?
Seth, can you read it off to me?
Start from the left,
the bottom left;
what is it?
What's the first group?
There's a carbon.
That's a single carbon.
Yeah, methyl, CH_3.
Right?
He doesn't draw the three bonds
to hydrogen separately,
but it's clearly C bonded to
three hydrogens.
What's next?
Keep going.
It's a C bonded to what?
The top left.
It's bonded to the methyl,
of course.
What else?
Student:  Oxygen and
hydrogen.
Prof: Bonded to oxygen,
to a single oxygen;
although he wrote two, right?
And what else is that carbon
bonded to?
Student:  Hydrogen.
Prof: How many?
How many hydrogens is it bonded
to?
The top left carbon.
Student:  Two.
Prof: The two.
So it's CH_3CH_2O.
Now, can someone help me out
with the rest of it?
Ryan?
Student:  Well wouldn't
that only just be one O at the
top because --
Prof: It should be one
O, but he's got the different
atomic weight.
John?
Student:  Shouldn't the
C's on the far right be bonded?
Prof: Ah,
the C's on the far right should
be bonded to one another.
The printer left that out.
So it's symmetrical.
It's diethyl ether.
Okay?
And it's the correct structure
for it, except for the printer's
error.
Okay?
Now, he says:
"There is no reaction
found where it is known that C^2
is divided into two parts.
It is only consequent therefore
to write,
as Gerhardt does,
C^2 simply as C,
it being understood that the
equivalent of carbon is
twelve."
So he changed it in this paper
to be twelve.
So now his formulas are going
to be more like ours,
without the C^2.
So he has a formula for
glycerin, and one for glyceric
acid.
So let's do glyceric acid.
What do you see up at the top?
What's the top carbon?
Max, what do you say?
What's it bonded to,
the carbon at the top,
on the right?
Student:  Bonded to a
hydrogen.
Prof: One hydrogen.
Student:  OH group.
Prof: An OH group.
Student:  And another --
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Another OH
group.
Prof: Two OH groups,
and the carbon below.
Right?
Because carbon can bond to
carbon;
that's the special thing about
it.
Okay, so here's the one on the
left, in a formula nowadays,
and there's the one on the
right.
And it turns out he guessed a
bit wrong, because he put two
OH's on the top part and none on
the middle one;
and it should be the other way
around.
So in truth he should've
changed those two.
Of course, he had no way of
knowing it.
And the same on the right.
Okay?
So he's pretty close with his
structure.
But probably the most
remarkable thing is his
structure for glucose,
which is shown here,
and which -- now,
he doesn't show the vertical
bonds between carbons.
He uses this curly bracket.
So that's a little reminiscent
of type theory.
But clearly that's what he
meant was the carbons to be
bonded to carbon.
So that's the formula he wrote.
And that's the correct
structure for glucose,
if it's hydrated.
Okay?
So you can add -- glucose is an
aldehyde, CHO on the bottom,
double bond O.
So you can add water to the
aldehyde;
that actually happens.
And you get the structure he
wrote here.
So it's right,
if the glucose is in water.
Right?
So try yourself.
This is a good exercise for
reviewing what we've been doing.
Depending on how you define it,
it's a two or a three-step
sequence of HOMO/LUMO
interactions that take water
plus an aldehyde into a diol;
which is what you have here.
So try that one out.
Okay?
And in the French version of
the same paper,
which as we said appeared a
little later,
he drew it this way.
And what do you notice is
different now?
There are two things different
actually.
Student:  Straight lines.
Prof: Yeah,
now he's drawing single lines,
straight lines for bonds.
So this is the first time that
was done;
none of those dotted lines
anymore.
But there's a typo.
Instead of drawing OH here --
and notice --
yeah, instead of drawing OOH
here,
for a second,
he added -- he's got the wrong
formula,
he's got H_2 there.
But this is really amazing,
that he got the correct
structure for such a complicated
molecule,
in the very first paper where
the idea of structure,
or of bonds altogether,
was proposed.
So this is really amazing.
And we owe to Couper the idea
of bonds, and the notation we
use to do them.
So here's Old Aisle Cemetery in
Kirkintilloch in Scotland,
yesterday.
And there you see that this is
the gravestone of Archibald
Scott Couper.
And down here is your thank-you
note.
>
And those are the flowers --
that's the heather you bought to
put on his tombstone.
So that was our secret
thank-you note.
And we thank Susan Frew for
being our agent and delivering
this yesterday.
>
Okay.
But on the front of the
building Couper doesn't get any
notice at all.
It's only you guys that are in
the know that can do that.
Right?
On the front of the building
they say Kekulé.
So let's talk about
Kekulé.
And we'll also talk about
Hofmann, who we've mentioned
before as the guy in the top-hat
on the right end of that picture
in Liebig's lab in Giessen.
And Cannizzaro.
Okay, this is a drawing that
Kekulé
made at the age of thirteen.
By my standards,
that's a pretty darn good
drawing.
And here's one he made at the
age of eighteen.
And he went to Giessen
University to study
architecture,
but while he was there he went
to Liebig's lectures and got
fascinated by chemistry and
became a chemist.
Okay.
He studied with Liebig and
after he finished he wanted to
go to Paris to study with the
people there.
Liebig, remember,
had worked with Gay-Lussac.
So he knew from Paris.
What do you think he would tell
Liebig, the young guy about to
go off to Paris?
Student:  Stay away from
Dumas.
Prof: Stay away from
Dumas perhaps,
right?
What he said was,
"There you will broaden
your horizons,
there you will learn a new
language,
there you will learn to know
the life of a great city,
but there you will not learn
chemistry."
But he went anyhow.
He also went to England and
became widely acquainted with
all the leading chemists of the
day.
Then he got a job in
Heidelberg, where he was from
1856 to '58, and he did research
on cacodyl;
that's that free radical
involving arsenic.
A remarkable -- his student,
who worked with him on that was
Baeyer, who we'll talk about a
lot later.
That was Bunsen,
who was the big cheese in
Heidelberg, was the one
Kekulé
was associated with.
And he did the work,
not in the laboratory,
but in the kitchen in his
apartment, this work on arsenic.
So in 1857, while he was there,
he proposed a new type,
based on carbon.
So carbon could have four
things attached to it,
which you could substitute one
for another.
Right?
So this was where he got the
idea of carbon being something
special, the basis of a new
type, and that it was
tetravalent.
And ultimately he got onto the
idea, a year later,
that carbon could link to
itself.
So he had proposed the marsh
gas type before Couper's paper.
But this other one was
essentially simultaneous;
just slightly later written but
earlier published.
Here are his Observations on
Mr. Couper's New Chemical
Theory.
"In fact,
in two memoirs which have
appeared in Liebig's
Annalen,
I have put forward different
views,
which, in my opinion,
should furnish a clearer
insight into the constitution of
chemical compounds."
"I may be allowed to
indicate that lays down the
principle...which I have called
the basicity of atoms."
"If Mr. Couper thinks he
has discovered the cause of this
difference of basicity in the
existence of a special kind of
affinity,
I am the first to admit that I
have no right to contest his
priority in this."
But he was quick to say that he
was the one that had the idea
first.
And he went to quite a
successful career,
in contrast to Couper.
Here he is in Ghent,
the period during which he
proposed the structure for
benzene, with a bunch of people
whom we will talk about later;
or at least several of them
we'll talk about later,
as his students.
And then he became the leader
in Bonn, in a big new chemistry
institute there.
Here he is in 1872.
And we'll talk a lot about this
guy on the right here.
So he became a really prime
leader in chemistry.
Now, facts, ideas and words.
Words means nomenclature.
So these new ideas needed new
words, and also not just words
written out with letters,
but notation;
what symbols are you going to
write for these things?
And a further development to
that is actual physical models
that you could put together to
show what you are talking about
with molecules;
if they have structure.
So Hofmann was great with
language.
He actually went and became a
leading professor in the Royal
College of Chemistry in London,
because Prince Albert -- you
know, Victoria and Albert --
Albert was a German.
So he had a lot of connections
with German chemistry and went
to Liebig.
Liebig said,
"Hofmann's a great guy,
you should get him."
So they got him.
So he came to London,
and was completely fluent in
English, and very good at
languages altogether.
And he'd had the idea of
systematizing the names of
hydrocarbons.
So he was going to base it on
Latin roots.
So four will be
"quart",
right?
What do we say for four?
Butane, right?
We talked about that last time.
So "quartane"
is the start.
And then you can start pulling
hydrogens off and have names for
the radicals.
So you could pull one hydrogen
off;
that's "quartyl".
Because yl,
remember, is the root that
means radical.
And then you can pull a second
hydrogen off;
then you have
"quartene".
And then you pull a third
hydrogen off,
it's "quartenyl".
And then "quartine,
quartinyl, quartone,
quartonyl, quartune,
quartunyl".
What was his system?
How can you remember which one
is "quartune"?
Yeah?
Student:  It's the
vowels.
Prof: It's the vowels in
order, a-e-i-o-u.
And we preserve the a,
the e and the i;
although we write y,
instead of i,
for alkyne.
Right?
That's where it came from,
from Hofmann.
But the quart didn't
stick, because but was
well established by then.
Okay, now how about
Kekulé's -- so that's
words.
How about notation?
So in the paper where he
proposed benzene,
in 1865, while he was Ghent,
he says, in a footnote:
"For greater clarity I am
presenting at the end of this
note a table giving graphical
formulae for most of the
substances mentioned.
The idea that these formulae
are designed to express is
rather well known now;
so it will not be necessary to
dwell upon it.
I am keeping the form that I
adopted in 1859 when expressing
for the first time my views on
the atomic constitution of
molecules."
So 1859 is at the time he was
proposing valence and so on;
1858, as I remember.
So this is now five,
six years later,
and he's applying it to
benzene.
"This form is nearly
identical with that which
Monsieur Wurtz used in his
beautiful lectures on chemical
philosophy.
It seems to me preferable to
the modifications proposed by
Messieurs Loschmidt and
Crum-Brown."
So let's first look at what
Loschmidt did,
and Crum-Brown.
So here's what they said,
to which Kekulé
considers his superior.
Well first let's think,
what should a formula show?
Right?
What's the very first thing a
formula should show?
It has to correspond with the
facts, right?
So what facts do you deduce
about a molecule?
What should the formula show?
Kevin?
Student:  What elements
are in the --
Prof: What elements are
there: carbon,
hydrogen, oxygen,
chlorine, nitrogen,
whatever.
Okay, what else?
Shai?
Student:  The ratio of
elements.
Prof: The ratio of the
elements, right?
Berzelius also had this.
But what's going to be new?
Composition:
the elements and the number of
atoms.
What next;
now, if we've got the new
theory, the valence theory?
Sherwin?
Student:  The structure.
Prof: The structure.
What do you mean by the
structure?
Student:  The relative
positioning.
Prof: You mean like
x,y,z
coordinates?
You could write numbers.
Here's the origin;
I'm going to give this 1.238
and so on.
What?
Student:  Then which
atoms are bonded.
Prof: Ah,
which ones are connected to one
another.
Right?
Not their positions in space;
but this is connected to this,
this valence goes there,
and so on.
Okay, so Berzelius was already
fine for composition.
But now we also need to show
Constitution -- that's the
second C is constitution --
which means the nature and
sequence of bonds.
Now sequence is clear.
This is bonded to this,
bonded to this one.
What do I mean by the
"nature"
of the bond?
How could bonds differ in their
nature?
Student:  Strength.
Prof: Single,
double, triple,
right?
So, and you need to be able to
show isomers,
which Berzelius couldn't show.
Okay? So here's Lohschmidt.
This is Lohschmidt's formula,
1861, for acetic acid.
Can you understand it?
Andrew, what do you say?
No hope.
What do you think the stuff on
the left is?
Student:  CH_3.
Prof: Pardon me?
Prof: CH_3, right?
So the size is something about
the weight, right?
So it's CH_3.
What's it bonded to?
C; same size.
Student:  O.
Prof: O, H;
and what's special?
Student:  Double bond.
Prof: Double bond.
So he's got a way of showing a
double bond, right?
So we can easily understand it.
Okay, now here's Crum-Brown.
Now that's benzoic acid in
Crum-Brown's paper.
So the COOH is even clearer
than it was in Loschmidt,
right?
What's a double and single bond.
The same thing we use now.
Okay?
What's different is the C_6
part and five hydrogens attached
to it.
But we don't really know how
the C_6 is arranged.
Although he also showed this
one, for phenol,
which is a benzene with a
hydroxyl group on it,
OH.
So there you see a ring.
It's double,
single, double,
single;
and H is attached to all the
carbons, except for one,
which has OH.
So that's easy to understand.
Shai?
Student:  Where does the
idea of double bonds come from?
I feel like it's just --
Prof: Because if you say
carbon has four,
then you have to figure out
where the fourth one is.
Right?
If it's associated with three
atoms, but can make four bonds;
it must make two to one of them.
That's the idea anyhow.
Or it could be that they go to
the center of the ring,
the fourth one and so on.
There are other ideas too.
Okay, or here is a reaction in
Crum-Brown's notation.
So it's an aldehyde.
You add the HOMO of cyanide,
and a proton to the O,
and you get that compound;
a cyanohydrin, as it's called.
So this is almost identical --
what difference is it from our
current, how different is it?
We don't draw circles around
the elements anymore;
that makes it faster to draw.
Otherwise it's essentially the
same.
Okay?
Or here, he says there are two
kinds of alcohols:
"true"
alcohol, which can lose water
and give an olefin;
or olefin hydrate,
which can lose water and give
the same olefin.
What's the difference between
the true alcohol and the olefin
hydrate?
How are they isomers?
Russell?
Student:  The position
of the OH.
Prof: Right,
the position of the OH relative
to the R.
Okay?
So he's explaining isomers
here.
So those are pretty good.
But Kekulé
says his is ever so much
better.
This is Kekulé's
structure of benzene,
from that same paper.
Remember he says at the end,
I'm going to give my superior
formulas.
So what in the heck is he
talking about?
Eric, you got any idea?
So what do you think that is?
Eric?
No idea?
Well you don't have much to
work with in benzene.
>
What do you have?
Prof: It's C_6H_6. Right?
So that's got to either be
carbon or hydrogen.
Which do you think?
Student:  Hydrogen.
Prof: The top left there.
No idea.
Anybody got an idea?
Why do you say carbon Kate?
Student:  Yeah,
because that one's showing
double and single bonds all
together.
Prof: Ah,
it's showing up above here,
the schematic one is showing
double bonds between carbons and
then a single bond;
then a double bond and a single
bond;
then a double bond.
Well let's go -- that's open
chain, and this is closed chain.
What are these arrows on the
end?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Ah,
those are the ones that loop
back and attach to one another,
somehow, to make a ring.
Okay?
Do you think he's trying to
give -- to imply Cartesian
coordinates, for the location of
every atom, by where he draws
these symbols?
Is he trying to show
x,y,z
coordinates?
What do you think Nate?
Think he thinks he's showing
that, or not?
Student:  I don't know.
Student:  Which Nate?
Prof: Either of you.
Student:  He's got
x,y.
There, he's got an
Prof: Oh you could say,
right, here's an x-axis and
there's a y-axis.
He says at a certain point it's
that, that, that,
that, that.
Do you think he thinks that if
he had a microscope and could
see it, that's where those atoms
would be, in fact?
Is it physical position he's
showing?
Student:  They look kind
of like
>
to me.
Prof: Kelsey,
you got an idea?
Do you think he thinks he's
showing where these atoms are
actually located in space?
What is he showing?
Yeah Sherwin?
Student:  The sequence.
Prof: What's bonded to
what, and whether it's single
bond or double bond.
He's showing Constitution,
the nature and sequence of
bonds;
not positions of atoms,
certainly not.
Okay, and then the little ones
are hydrogens,
right?
So the length of one of these
things is how many valences it
has.
Right? Four long, for carbon;
only one long for hydrogen.
And tangency then means a bond.
Right?
So this is C-H double bond;
C-H single bond;
C-H double bond, and so on.
And then you get to the end,
you go back to the beginning.
Okay?
Now he then shows chlorinated
benzene, because chlorine is
also monovalent.
Right?
So you can substitute for
hydrogen, and then you could
have dichlorobenzene too,
or tri-, or tetra-,
and so on.
Right?
Now is he showing isomers here?
That is, in this case,
if you substituted this one for
the chlorine,
instead of that one;
same thing or different things?
If you believe that this was a
picture of things in space,
they'd be different.
Right?
But if all you're interested in
is what's connected to what,
by single and double bonds,
then it's the same.
You have the same pattern
either way.
How about for the dichloro?
Would there be isomers of that?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Ah,
you could get different
sequence, right?
They could be adjacent carbons
that have chlorines,
or next adjacent,
or beyond that.
Right?
So you could use this system to
talk about isomers.
So how many isomers?
Now what do you think
Kekulé
thought?
What do you think he thought
about how many isomers of
chlorobenzene there are?
Do you think he thought there
was many?
Just what -- guess.
I'm going to show you.
Okay, he thinks his system is
superior.
Now he also used his system --
in this same paper he did a lot
of formulas.
But he showed these compounds.
Like this one.
What's that group, on the left?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: What's the group
here?
What is that?
What's this atom?
CH_3.
What's this?
CH_2. OH;
O is two units long, right?
So CH_3CH_2CH_2OH.
Alcool propylique;
propyl alcohol.
Now what's this one?
CH_3_, CH_3, CH, OH.
It's alcool méthyle-&
eacute;thylique;
methyl ethylic alcohol.
So this would be ethyl alcohol,
the part on the top.
But we've got a methyl
substituted in it.
And notice, he's having to
change his formula,
because now these are
horizontal tangencies that are
bonds,
but this vertical tangency
doesn't count as a bond.
So it's getting a little
complicated to explain to
students.
Right?
Okay, what's the next one?
CH_3.
What's this?
Prof: C double bond O.
CH_3.
So that's our old friend
acetone.
And what's this one?
CH_3.
CH-OH.
Right?
CH_3.
Alcool acétonique.
So it's the alcohol you get by
adding two hydrogens to acetone.
Now what do you think about
this?
Do you see anything interesting?
This one is CH_3CHOHCH_3.
This one is CH_3CHCH_3OH.
Sophie, what do you say?
Student:  They're the
same thing.
Prof: Ah,
they're the same nature and
sequence of bonds.
Right? That one is what we know.
That's that one.
That one, that one.
But the last,
and number twenty-eight here,
are the same thing,
but he draws different formulas
for them.
So his system is not showing
isomerism properly.
Right? He drew these different.
He didn't say that they were
the same.
Right?
And they were thought to be
different.
Because when you do one -- when
you prepare it one way and when
you prepare it another way,
you get a different boiling
point say, or something.
I actually don't know what the
data was, but there was some
difference that said there were
these two different compounds.
Did you ever get a wrong
boiling point?
So did they.
Right?
It just turned out the
experiment was wrong.
But that shows that his system
is not as good as these other
systems;
whatever he said.
Okay, now how about physical
models of molecules?
Well here's a great patent that
was issued by the U.S. Patent
Office to Samuel M. Gaines of
Glasgow, Kentucky,
in 1868.
And we can read about his
description of what was so good
about this.
He says, "Now,
if a class thus instructed be
at the recitation bench"
"and one of them is
requested to form carbonic acid,
he will walk quickly to the
table in front,
where the box is open,
and place on one of the shelves
a cube marked 6,
and two marked 8.
Carbon, one, and oxygen,n two.
If requested to form lime,
he will place on the shelf a
cube marked 20,
(calcium,) and another one
marked 8, (oxygen.)
these being the elements of
lime.
These cubes being all placed in
contact, and the pupil being
asked, 'What have we now?'
answers ‘carbonate of
lime'."
Right?
Okay.
"Another pupil may then be
asked to give the proximate
analysis for carbonate of lime.
And the cubes before him will
indicate the answer and fix it
in his memory:
‘It is composed of one
equivalent of carbonic acid,
(22) and one of lime,
(28)'."
"Another may be requested
to give the ultimate analysis,
and by the same means he is
furnished with the answer.
‘Carbonic acid is
composed of one atom of carbon,
two of oxygen,
and lime is composed of one
atom of calcium and one of
oxygen.'
The intelligent educator will
see at a glance,
that in this chemical alphabet
he has the means of at once
arresting the attention of his
class and converting what had
hitherto been an irksome task
into a pleasant recreation.
The atomic theory,
the characteristics of
affinity,
the law of multiple
proportions, the nomenclature,
isomerism, etc.,
may all be learned in half the
time required heretofore,
and learned so as not likely
ever to be forgotten."
Now what do you think?
Would this show the atomic
theory that molecules are
substances that are composed of
atoms?
Does it show it?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Yeah.
Okay, how about the
characteristics of affinity;
single, double,
triple bond,
valence and so on,
show that?
Not in any obvious way that I
can see.
So I doubt that one.
How about the law of multiple
proportions?
Remember what the law of
multiple proportions was?
You have the same elements --
if you have a parts of A and b
parts of B, and so on,
all that stuff,
then what AD will be,
and so on.
Yes Max?
Student:  Why did
Kekulé
only show one oxygen,
in his notation?
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  Did
Kekulé
know what the exact mass of
oxygen was?
Because he only had one in his
notation.
Prof: Yes,
but notice everything here is
halved.
Student:  Oh okay.
Prof: So it's okay,
the right proportions,
right?
Okay?
But multiple proportions,
you have to know something
about how many of one associates
with how many of another;
which isn't obvious here.
Okay?
Nomenclature?
Well maybe, calcium oxide and
so on, CO_2.
Isomerism, that you can have
the same things differently
arranged?
Well obviously you can put the
blocks on top of one another or
beside one another.
But how do you know how many
you should do?
Right?
Not very clear to me that this
system works well.
So those models are good for
some things, but not good for an
awful lot of things.
Okay, now James Dewar in
Scotland, a student,
had the idea of using brass
strips to show models.
And, in fact,
he could put these black balls
on.
He said, "To make the
combination look like an atom,
a thin round disc of blackened
brass can be placed under the
central nut."
I think that's really cute,
to "look like an
atom," as if he knew what
an atom looked like.
Right?
Okay, so then he drew -- he
made these models from his
strips of possible structures of
benzene.
Right?
You can see where the atoms
are, and the four valences on
every carbon,
and what they -- which
direction they go.
That particular one,
that compound,
that structure,
was actually prepared about 100
years later, and when it was,
it was called Dewar benzene.
Right?
That one's interesting.
It's got a four-center bond,
four carbons all sharing the
same bond.
Right?
Hofmann, the guy,
remember, who was good at
language and was in London;
his last lecture in London was
at the Royal Institution,
the place where Faraday was,
and where Davy had been and did
the experiments on electrolysis.
So he gave this public lecture
where he used croquet balls for
atom models,
with sticks stuck in them,
and he colored them,
and the system he chose is the
one we still use for what color
the atoms are:
white for hydrogen,
red for oxygen,
blue for nitrogen,
black for carbon.
Okay?
So here's part of the lecture
he gave.
So he would build molecules
before your very eyes.
He'd start with a hydrogen,
put an oxygen on,
and another hydrogen;
lo, he's made water.
Right?
Or he could make marsh gas,
methane.
Or he could show the oxides of
HCl.
So you start with HCl,
but he could take it apart and
put an oxygen in between,
or put two oxygens,
or three or four oxygens in
between.
You'd go from hydrochloric to
hypochlorous to chlorous to
chloric to perchloric.
So this is like Lavoisier,
going to different levels of
oxidation.
Unfortunately,
those aren't the structures.
Right?
What really happens is that the
unshared pair of chlorine can
share with oxygen to give this,
which is the active ingredient
in Clorox bleach.
Or you can use another unshared
pair of chlorine to put another
oxygen.
Or another for another,
and get the oxidizing agent
that Gay-Lussac used,
the chlorate.
Or you can put a last one.
And this is an explosive.
In fact, ammonium perchlorate,
AP, is a component of military
explosives.
Notice that in Hofmann's thing
you could've put fifteen oxygens
in a row if you could have
reached high enough.
But you can only go to four
here, because that's how many
unshared-pairs chlorine has --
choride has to use.
Okay, but then he showed the
chlorination of marsh gas.
So monochlorinated,
dichlorinated,
trichlorinated and
tetrachlorinated marsh gas.
Now this is interesting because
for the dichloro,
you could imagine having two
isomers with these models.
Right?
The chlorines could be near one
another or opposite one another.
Right?
Now some years later there was
an exhibition in London and they
showed molecular models.
By this time Hofmann was back
in Germany.
But they got a guy in Spain to
make some Hofmann-style models.
Manuel Gonzalez Rodriguez from
Madrid made this set.
And here's chloromethane made
from that set.
What's the difference between
these -- it says "according
to Hofmann"
here, "Segun
A.W. Hofmann".
Right?
What's the difference?
Alex?
Student:  Bonds on the
carbon aren't just- aren't
90° from each other.
Prof: They're not
90° from one another.
They're 109.5°
from one another.
It's a tetrahedron,
not a square plane.
Right?
Now what does that say about
isomers?
So suppose we substitute
another chlorine.
There's a dichloro;
there's a different dichloro;
there's a different dichloro.
How about it?
Student:  No.
Prof: They're just
rotated from another.
They're not different, right?
So depending on whether it's
square plane or tetrahedral,
you'll get different numbers of
isomers.
That's neat,
because it gives you a tool for
telling whether it's square
plane or tetrahedral.
Right?
So you can get structure from
analysis.
So, but these constitutional
models try to show the nature
and sequence of bonds for
Hofmann, not the arrangement in
space;
and not for Hofmann,
and not for the guy that made
these models.
They weren't trying to explain
isomers in that way.
All they were trying to show
was the same thing you draw in
these pictures:
the nature and the sequence of
bonds;
whether they're single or
double, triple,
and what's associated with
what.
So that comes a little later,
trying to get to the
arrangement in space.
But the pièce de
résistance of
Hofmann's lecture was this:
that if you take these croquet
ball models and make the
olefiant gas,
which we talked about last
time, it's got two spare
valences,
and if you add chlorine you can
get the dutch liquid,
the dichloroethane.
But remember what we saw last
time.
He called olefiant gas
"unfinished"
or "not saturated";
we now call it an unsaturated
molecule.
And it's reactive because of
these dangling valences.
And we now know why it's that
way.
That he's got the wrong
structure;
it should be CH_2CH_2,
not CHCH_3.
And we know about HOMOs and
LUMOs now.
But that was what he really
showed, was that the model had
something completely new that no
one anticipated.
It could explain what,
that's new?
What new qualities has he
associated with the models?
What elements are there,
what ratio they're in.
Right?
How they're linked to one
another, single,
double, triple bonds.
What's he adding?
Reactivity.
Right?
So it's something new.
So the whole history is adding
new things, new properties to
the models.
And there are more to come.
Okay.
Okay, that's it.